Північ Чернігівщини. Зорієнтуватися в місцевих лісах допомагають паперові карти.
Вони ведуть нас усе ближче до білоруського кордону.
Ця місцевість першою зустріла російський наступ у лютому.
У квітні ЗСУ звільнили Чернігівщину. Утім війна весь час поруч.
Це російська техніка, яку кинули при відступі. В наших лісах її дуже багато. Ми патрулюємо ці позиції, цей ліс.
І велика гордість у нас за такі трофеї, за наші Збройні сили України.
Тобто це колишні російські позиції?
Так, це колишня російська позиція.
Російська САУ тепер служить на позиціях українських військових.
Вони готові зустрічати нову партію техніки з півночі.
Я думаю, усе може повторитися знову.
Тому що інші фронти вони програють і їм треба ухвалити інше рішення, відкрити новий фронт.
Дмитрові 31 рік, до повномасштабного вторгнення він працював на залізниці.
За вісім місяців війни він бачився з дружиною і трирічним сином загалом не більше двох тижнів.
Каже, рідні підтримують його в телефонних розмовах. А сил додає злість.
Моя злість з'являється через те, що їхній народ підтримує загибель мирних жителів.
Якби ми гралися у війнушки і гинули б військові, не було б такої образи.
А коли весь народ радіє загибелі дітей, покаліченим дітям, яким невідомо, як далі жити, - від цього злість бере.
На позиціях чергує і чернігівець Максим. Хлопцеві 20 років. Утім на молодий вік він не зважає.
В мене зараз найкраща фізична форма, я легко навчаюся.
У нас народ зараз не поділений на вікові категорії.
Ми служимо. Побратими в мене з вісімнадцяти років і до шістдесяти. Ми всі на рівних.
Усі військові, каже Максим, однаково готові до бою.
Протягом восьми місяців повномасштабної війни вони багато чому навчилися у побратимів із досвідом.
У нас війна йде не з 24 лютого, як пояснюють.
У нас війна триває вже більше восьми років.
У нас були бійці, які служили там, брали участь у бойових діях з 2014 року.
Вони навчені, підготовлені. Завдяки цим людям ми можемо служити і відчувати себе впевнено.
На цих обладнаних у лісі позиціях ніхто не сподівається, що все минеться.
Військові звикли готуватися до гіршого. Тим паче на тлі останніх новин.
Мінськ і Москва офіційно об'єднують сили.
Росія перекидає військових і техніку на територію свого союзника.
За даними українського Генштабу, з початку жовтня Білорусь активно перевіряє мобілізаційні ресурси.
Опозиційні білоруські медіа повідомляють про приховану мобілізацію.
Водночас Олександр Лукашенко заявляє про постійні провокації з боку України
та загрозу на західних кордонах його держави.
Вони кажуть, що готові захищатися. Але українці тут, на кордоні з Білоруссю певні:
те що називають обороною, насправді буде атакою.
От тільки коли вона почнеться - невідомо.
Мешканці цього прикордонного села живуть у страху.
Вони розповідають, що військові РФ розташувалися всього за 30 кілометрів звідси.
Тим не менш, більшість не має наміру виїжджати.
Куди я поїду? Я тут народилася, і тут дітей своїх і чужих виховувала, і я поїду? До кого, до чого я поїду?
Пенсіонерка Валентина прожила в цьому селі все життя.
Вона з острахом згадує про події лютого й не хоче, аби вони повторилися.
У березні в нас не було, а в лютому були, стояли.
Оце як дорога в нас - колона стояла, ціла колона.
Ми так боялися, що не спали ні вдень, ні вночі.
І вони потім годині о десятій вечора почали стріляти такими ракетами, що світяться.
Валентина найбільше переймається через дітей, які нині в Чернігові.
Сама жінка й не замислюється над тим, аби залишити своє господарство.
Це, як кажуть, наша батьківщина. Ми народилися тут і живемо тут. Ми нікуди не підемо звідси.
Сільську крамницю розграбували росіяни, коли зайшли в село в лютому, розповідає продавчиня Анна.
Їй образливо, що прохід російським військовим дозволила Білорусь, яку жінка вважала добрим сусідом.
Раніше дружили ми з Білоруссю, а тепер що… Погані враження про них, особливо про Білорусь.
Раніше вони до нас їздили в Чернігів за покупками, а тепер ворогами зробили.
Аби наступ з півночі не повторився знову, військові готові покласти свої голови.
Олексій у минулому лікар-ветеринар. У чоловіка троє дітей і троє онуків. Він знає, за що бореться.
Я хочу, щоб ця війна зупинилася на мені. Я не хочу…
Мої онуки вже й так дізналися, що таке війна, знають, що таке обстріли. Втрачали своїх друзів.
Син мій теж військовий, я військовий, зять військовий.
Втрачати є що. Так, життя - воно одне. Але нехай краще це буду я, ніж мої діти, онуки.
Голова української військової розвідки Кирило Буданов вважає, що нині на території Білорусі
немає достатньо ресурсу для нового наступу.
Водночас військові на білоруському кордоні припускають,
що чекати "гостей" з півночі можна, коли підмерзне земля для проходу техніки.
Вони більше не довіряють сусідам, яких колись вважали "братами".